wenn ihr wissen wollt wie man Nashville
Haut schicken macht dann schaut dieses
Video wir fangen an mit der Marinade
Buttermilch Paprika schwarzer Pfeffer
und Salz das ganze umrühren
hähnchenkoteletts das Beste und
saftigste Fleisch vom Hähnchen und
Marinade drüber die Hauptarbeit macht
die Zeit 24 Stunden später okay das ist
Saftigkeit restliche Marinade Mehl
Paprika Pfeffer Salz vermixen wir nehmen
chicken wem das hier rein so in die
Marinade noch mal ins Mehl Zack und hier
ist es unser auserwähltes chicken
anschau Chili Cayennepfeffer Knoblauch
brauner Zucker und geräucherte Paprika
Suppenkelle und einen Löffel heißes Öl
und ab geht's
alles verbinden oh dieser Geruch chicken
rein okay der Farbton und wir nehmen
unsere Nashville Soße und streichen Sie
auf das Chicken
ich kann das nicht allein probieren Eric
days hallo